i'm going to talk about dart
i'm super excited to actually be here at
strange loop i
you know kind of walking around the
hallways i feel like the
just the the caliber of programmer here
that i'm around is
is really exciting being able to give it
talk to you guys is a super bonus but
just being here is really awesome
my name is bob nystrom but my sort of
online alter ego
is munificent i was at a talk a couple
years
ago and had my normal human meat space
name
on my name tag and of course no one
knows who i am and then i
put my reddit name on it and i had a
couple of people after that be like oh
you're that guy
which is weird um so i guess maybe bob
is my alter ego and this is my
my real ego i'm not sure which one
i work for google i'm on the dart team
this is uh this is not actually what the
dart team looks like we have much better
gender and ethnic diversity on the team
but we don't look as cool
as the 1887 penn state qriket team so i
figured i'd do that
instead okay so here's
the high level overview of dart if you
accidentally walked into this room and
intended to be somewhere else starts a
web language
that puts it in the camp of lots of
other high-level languages
it's object oriented but it also has a
bunch of functional features
it's a dynamic language the runtime
semantics are
dynamically typed or dynamically
dispatched or duct typed or
you know whatever terminology you prefer
there
but it also has an optional static type
system
it's a starts a web language but in
particular it's a client-side web
language so it runs
in your browser we have a server-side
story too but the main focus of the team
is to
to be a better language in the browser
and that means the
you know the the ticket price for being
that is that dart compiles to javascript
like uh coffeescript closure script lots
of other languages
but unlike most other languages in the
in the browser we also have
um a native virtual machine for dart
makes for a really nice development
story it means you can
you know debug step through you know the
the native dart code without having to
kind of squint through
you know generated code
and then finally uh the languages is
pretty much here so we're
we're creeping up pretty closely to
declaring 1.0
we've uh we're using it internally on
several projects at google none of which
i can currently talk about of course
we've got hundreds of packages of dart
code online
on the dart package manager we've
there's thousands of dart repos on
github
we're starting to go through the process
of creating an open standard for it
so core library is a pretty stable
language is pretty stable we're trying
to get you know kind of out of
figuring out what we're doing into where
a real language you can use on
production apps
so if this is a normal talk
the next you know 35 minutes or so would
be just kind of a general introduction
to dart
syntax and semantics but i i figured i
have
i'm very fortunate to have a really
sophisticated audience so i wanted to
talk about
some more you know kind of deeper more
interesting ideas behind dart
but since you guys probably haven't
written much dart code you need
something so instead of doing a slow
general introduction
i'm going to do a really fast one and
i'm just going to run through a bunch of
dart stuff really quick
just kind of open your mind and let it
wash in
so this is hello world in dart function
declarations look
kind of like c execution starts at main
you declare local variables using var
[Music]
you can declare them at the top level
you'll notice that we're using it
[Music]
after it's being declared at the top
level top level variables will be lazily
evaluated the first time you use it so
the order doesn't matter
got some nice little string
interpolation going on you can do any
expression in there
what else we got we so functions are
first class
so here we're i can barely see the
highlighting going on there there is
some highlighting right you can see that
so here we're you know taking a
reference to the message function
storing it in a variable
calling it through that variable when
you have first class functions
oops of course you want anonymous
functions so we have these
anonymous functions here we're storing
it in a variable so it doesn't look very
anonymous
and then for the cases where you
have a lambda an anonymous function
where the body is just an expression
we've got some nice little arrow syntax
for that
what else of course uh these are all
closures so here we have this parameter
who
we're referring to it in a function it's
declared outside of that function when
we return it and later invoke it
the variable's still around closures are
wonderful
we've got list literals they look very
familiar very exciting
we have map literals too put those
together that means jason
is also valid dart syntax which is kind
of nice
so i said dart's a an object-oriented
language it's um it's class-based so
every object is an instance of a class
the language has
some nice declarative syntax for classes
built into it
this is the simplest way to define a
class
add fields to it like this um unlike a
lot of other dynamic languages fields
are explicitly
declared in dart i don't know if you
went to slava's talk earlier but he
talked about how that
helps the implementation optimize things
that part's true and it's nice the
reason i'm particularly excited about
this is it
means when you're looking at code you
can reason about the state of an object
just by
you know scanning the text you don't
have to see oh is it is some other
random code stuffing an extra property
on my object that i don't know about
i've got constructors they look kind of
familiar if you're coming from something
like java
if also like java they look kind of bad
so here we're referencing health three
times which is perverse
so we also have some nice syntactic
sugar where here
we're initializing the field
automatically from the parameter
what other fun stuff methods look like
functions declared inside a class
because methods are functions declared
inside
a class they're called the normal way
we've also got getters they look like
fields when you use them
but their implementation is some
computation
and correspondingly we have setters
these are completely indistinguishable
from fields in fact in the language
semantics
the language doesn't have fields it just
has these magic getters and setters
and the nice thing about that is it
means you don't have to
speculatively wrap things in getters and
setters you can just make something a
field when that's
what you need now and later if you need
to do some validation or something you
switch it out to a getter
no one is the wiser
okay what are some other fun stuff so we
have these little arrows for lambdas
and uh we thought it would be cool to
also be able to use that for for named
members so when you're declaring a
method or something if the body is just
an expression
you can go ahead and use an arrow there
too which is kind of nice for you know
little
one line members
we've got single inheritance because the
deadly diamond of death is
deadly but of course classes can
implement multiple interfaces
having to do that manually is sort of a
pain so
dart also has this thing called mixins
they're i believe very similar
to ruby mix-ins and plus or minus
similar to traits in scala
but basically they give you a way to
combine the method sets of multiple
classes into your class
without the craziness of
real multiple inheritance you still have
a single inheritance chain in the result
i would love to talk more about mixons i
think they're really cool
okay so did i lose you how many of you
i don't know if your the blank faces
mean you were lost or the blank faces
mean you're like i totally get it
did did you totally get it okay i see
thumbs up this is great okay
so this is awesome because now i have
time left so
for the rest of the talk i wanted to
talk about some you know kind of more
interesting stuff
but languages aren't created in a vacuum
right so what i thought would be
interesting would be to talk about some
ideas in dart but to talk about them in
the context
of other languages that have similar
ideas and hopefully i can
show some connections or maybe some
differences um
that sound cool okay so here's the way
it's going to work it's
there's some mandatory audience
participation here so we're going to do
this like a trivia game
for every other language you guys are
going to have to guess it so i'll give
you some clues
and then you as soon as you have an idea
you yell out the answer
um this is gonna be awesome it's totally
gonna work
okay so language number one uh clue
number one
lars bach the creator of dart has also
implemented a high performance virtual
machine for this language
the spec was edited by guy steele
there you go okay so language number one
java
uh so when java was created can you see
the
does it look like a star field a pretty
universe so java wasn't created
in a vacuum right like when the sun guys
created it there was this this looming
other language there
and gosling and company created java
specifically in that context they
created it knowing that c
plus was there and sort of as a reaction
to c plus
and i think there's two interesting
ideas that java has
that they that they use to deal with
that fact um
so so here's here's the first one so
let's say you are james gosling and
you're trying to figure out what java is
going to be
and you need it to be something that
will get people using c plus plus to
switch to you
so the obvious idea is you're like okay
well i'll just
kind of do something value-added right
like i'll just add a bunch of features
to c plus plus and that's clearly
more than c plus so people will use it
right um
the the hard thing about that is first
finding features that cbs plus doesn't
already have
it took surprisingly long to make this
slide
and then but the other problem with that
is like what's the worst thing about c
plus plus
features it's too complex right so so
their idea was
what we're going to do is we're going to
start with c plus plus and we're going
to subtract stuff
and in fact the original project name
for java before it was even oak was
c plus plus minus minus plus plus they
were like we're going to take some stuff
away and
add a couple of other things to you so
here's the stuff they they took away and
their
their idea was if we simplify things
people will be able to use java and get
stuff done faster
and it turns out there's there's legit
science behind this so have you guys
ever heard of hicks law seen hick's law
before
this is a law from psychology a real
empirical scientific law with
experiments and stuff
and it relates the number of options
a person has to choose from to how long
it takes for them to choose that
so here n is the number of things you're
selecting from imagine you're at a
restaurant you've got a menu what do you
want to have for dinner
tv is how long it picks it takes for you
to pick your entree
um and b here is some empirical constant
that's determined from
you know experimentation so the
interesting thing here is that there's a
positive correlation right so the more
options you have the longer
it takes you to decide so um
so the idea with java was we'll take a
bunch of stuff away from you
so this is here's a bunch of stuff that
you just don't have to spend time
thinking about when you're programming
in java compared to c plus plus
and that's that's cool that's that's a
win right so not only does it take you
less time
but also you don't have the opportunity
to pick these things wrong right like
there's fewer mistakes you can make
okay so let's talk about dart so dart
you know also was not created in a
vacuum
it's a web language and a client-side
web language so the main kind of
language occupying that space is
javascript but
you know there's lots of other languages
in that space too
i personally think that the the web has
grown so quickly that there is sort of a
partial vacuum in there like
you know the the set of things that
we're doing on the web is extremely
diverse now so i think there actually is
sort of room for lots of languages in
here
um but you know when we talk about
simplification that's usually relative
to something so i'll talk about it
first in the in the context of java
since that's the language we're talking
about so let's see
how dart is you know a bit simpler than
java
here's some some java code trivia time
how many different
kinds of access controller in this
example
four there's also package private right
so there's this is implicit so
when you're writing java code you have
you have to think about okay well what's
what's the level of access i want for
each of these members and then there's
there's verbose syntax required to be
able
to be able to express all those
different options right
so dart dart has some levels of privacy
control but it just has two
it has public and private it doesn't
have
any reserved words for this instead it
uses a naming convention if it's under
starts from the underscore it's private
otherwise it's public privacy and dart
is
um is library or module based so when
something's private it means it's
private to the entire module not to the
class declaring it
and you can have multiple classes in a
module and that lets you do some really
interesting patterns that i would
totally like to have more time to talk
about but i probably don't
okay so here's just some kind of this is
sort of a random set of other things
that
compared to java that you don't really
have to think about in dart so java has
method overriding but it also has a
method overloading overwriting is
dynamically dispatched overloading is
statically dispatched based on the
static types of the parameters
these two features interact with each
other it's a little bit confusing
starts a single dispatch language so it
has overriding but it doesn't have
overloading you just look up the method
by name that is your method
java you have classes and interfaces you
need classes because that's where you
can implement stuff but you need
interfaces if you want to not use that
implementation if you want to mock
things out
so you end up kind of doing both and
you're honestly right back to c
plus header files so in dart dart only
has
class declarations syntactically but
every class gives you a free interface
that is the the signature of that class
so you can make a concrete class foo
and then you just say i implement foo
and that means i'm using the the
interface defined by that class you
never have to kind of preemptively
make these interfaces in java you have
that issue of
you have to make all your fields private
and wrap them in getters and setters
because the syntax is different you may
want to go from one to the other later
in dart the syntax is the same so you
just do whatever makes sense for your
implementation and you're not locked
into anything
java has arrays and lists arrays have a
nice syntax lists have nice semantics
would have been nice if they put them
together dart just has a single growable
list built into the language that has
all the nice semantics you want and nice
literal forms and stuff like that
you've got primitive numbers primitive
values in java and then boxed values
there's auto boxing unboxing it's
confusing
dart to pure object oriented language
everything is an object so everything
kind of has the same
reference semantics a bunch of different
number types to pick from
dart just has ins and floats um
so that's kind of java but it's probably
more relevant to compare dart to
javascript because that's
you know kind of the domain where darts
more frequently used
so i'll walk you through one example so
one thing you do
writing code even when you're writing
javascript code is kind of define kinds
of things
data structures we can call them classes
but that's a voodoo word for some people
in javascript but you know kinds of
stuff right
um javascript doesn't have any syntax
for that not yet not until es6
so there's patterns right so here's
here's one kind of common this is like
the vanilla
pattern for defining a monster class in
javascript
there's other patterns some people like
to close over the instant state and
define the methods on the object there's
some pros and cons there maybe you
prefer to use a framework so here
if you're using dojo this is how you
would make a class or maybe here you're
using prototype
and all of these are fine like there's
nothing wrong with any of these but you
have to pick right like you think
you want to be thinking about monsters
but what you're thinking about is meta
programming
a meta object protocol in javascript
right um
so with dart you know we just say here
dart has classes
if you want to make a monster this is
the way you make a monster pretty
straightforward
and the nice thing about baking it into
the language is we can give you pretty
nice syntax for it too so it's kind of
declarative
so i'll just kind of run through a
couple of other sort of
hairy corners of javascript that you
know we've kind of subtracted out of
dart um
javascript has a lot of scary implicit
conversions i'm assuming most of you
guys have seen
gary bernhard's watt talk it's a lot
about that
um so in dart we don't do any implicit
conversions whatsoever if you have a
number and you want it to be a string
you better stringify it and if you have
a string you want it to be a number you
better parse it and we don't
pretend to know what you want to do
javascript has some
complex rules for truthiness if you use
you know some value as the condition in
an if expression
which things are truthy and which things
are falsy things like a list is falsy
but
or truthy unless it's empty then it's
it's hairy i should know it better than
i do honestly um
in dart we just say you know true is the
only true value everything else is false
dart has function scope it syntactically
looks like it has block scope because it
inherits it from c
but actually all of those nested local
variable declarations get
pushed up to the top level if you think
you're shadowing a variable you're
probably
not actually shadowing a variable and if
you think you're closing over a local
variable you may not be closing over the
variable you think you are
which is why you end up doing things
like ifes immediately invoked function
expressions
so dart has true lexical block scope
when you do var
that's where the var exists when that
cur when you hit the end curly that var
is no longer there
and in fact in loops every loop
iteration you'll get a fresh variable
there so if you're closing over your
loop variables they'll do the right
thing
this is one of those things where like
if you've been burned by you're like i'm
excited about that and if you're not
you're like i don't understand what the
guy's talking about
this is kind of related to function
scope javascript has this thing called
hoisting
which is that variable and especially
function declarations
the name the declaration of the name
gets pushed to the top of the scope and
then the definition stays where it is
um that's kind of a hack to let
mutual recursion sort of work
automatically in javascript you declare
two functions they want to call each
other
if we didn't hoist the first function
couldn't see the second one yet
so they do hoisting to kind of get
around that
so in dart the top level of your program
is just declarations sort of like
you know java or you know any kind of
static language and all those
declarations are simultaneous right so
you get mutual recursion and stuff like
that and it just works
and then within the body of that when
you're actually in imperative code land
there's no strange hoisting or playing
with your scoping right
uh javascript has it's prototype-based
it has an
interesting approach to understanding
how methods are associated with objects
um it's kind of cool from a language
nerd perspective but it has some weird
side effects and one of them is
if you close over this in the body of a
method
you don't really close over this you
think you did and you'll forget
you know who that method is being called
on at some point later
i don't know if that makes sense but if
you've ever seen javascript code that
says var that
equals this and you're like i don't get
what's going on here it's working around
this
so dart actually has a well-defined
distinction between a function and a
method
and we can just we can bind this when
you do a closure in a method which is
super nice
uh javascript's a very imperative
language so when you're defining
structures objects classes kinds of
types you're doing it by sort of
imperatively poking stuff into a bag of
state
right um dart has a kind of static
top-level structure so
when you're declaring a class you're
literally declaring it you're doing it
declaratively
and if you want to sort of mix and match
stuff together we have this mix-in
feature and that's also statically
resolved
okay so that's idea number one is
basically that
you can make a language that's more
productive for users by actually
being simpler than what what they're you
know what they had before
this is idea number two so
this is a programmer's brain right looks
like a brain
this is your awesome language so what's
the what's the problem here
problem is your awesome language is not
in their brain right so like
your language has all these cool
features and a lot of the reason to even
have those features
is just to motivate that brain to be
wanting to get it in there right but
that's really hard
like think about it it literally does
have to be ocr
to get it in there right like there's no
other way to get it in
so and it's extra hard because
there's usually some other language that
you don't like that's already in there
so they're like why am i motivated to
take your language i already got one
there's a trick you can do and the trick
is you make your language look like the
one they already know
right so when you do that they don't
have to learn your language they just
have to learn your semantics and your
semantics are a lot smaller
so when i spent a lot of time on that
animation i hope you guys appreciate
that
so you know c came out there was created
primordially
when c plus came out they're like we're
gonna make it look like c
java came out make it look like c plus
javascript looks like java c sharp looks
like java dart
kind of looks like all of these um so
for example so
if you know c you can read this program
and this is actually a valid dart
program
if you know java you can read this
program it's also dart
javascript mostly dart
because we don't have a function keyword
but very close
um and it's hard to stress
how important this is so this is the
kaiob language popularity index
um there are valid methodological flaws
with it but this is like a rough
approximation of the most popular
languages in the world right now
these are the languages that look kind
of like c so if you're making a language
and your goal is to get
to get it into the brains of you know
millions of developers there's
no language choice you can do better
than look like c right
um but that does leave you with a
conundrum right so i've got these two
ideas
take away a bunch of semantics keep a
bunch of syntax
what do you do with the syntax for the
semantics that you took away um
this is one of the things that i that i
really like about dart so this is a
bunch of stuff that's valid dart syntax
right valid java and c2 you've got you
know
property accessors indexers like
subscript operators
you know infix operators prefix
operators function calls
so in dart semantically all of these are
just
regular dynamically dispatched method
calls they're just
it's just syntax sugar for a method call
with a funny name so when you're
reasoning about that code
you know you kind of have to know the
grammar but you already know it because
c was drilled into your minds
at birth and then the semantics are
really easy to reason about
but that doesn't mean so i think it's
great starting with a familiar syntax
but it doesn't mean you have to stop
there right
so the the idea is if you start with a
syntax they already know
then when they come to your language
they can already express
everything they could express before
they don't have to spend time getting
back up to where they were in that other
language
but then you can build on top of that
right you can add more stuff so
i showed you some stuff already you know
initializing fields more simply
having a nice arrow function for
defining methods um
we've got some more stuff we've got so
we've got uh
optional arguments you know here we're
passing it here we aren't
we've got named parameters you can kind
of mix and match which ones you provide
um we have this double dot is called a
cascade operator which uh
is a way to send a call a bunch of
methods on the same receiver so here
all of those ad calls are on the the
same buffer object
it's kind of nice there's some some
deeper complexity as to why it's nice
but
again i won't go into it but i would
love to talk to you more about it
okay so these are these are the two kind
of cool ideas
um from java so
number two trivia time okay so
um this language is minimal
been around a while gets called an
assembly language
if only i don't know if i could even do
that that would be great
c is the right answer okay so does
everyone know who this guy is who is
this guy
dennis ritchie what is his most
important contribution
no inventing hello world
in order to do that he also had to
create c
so c was based on this language called
bcpl created by richard martin at the
university of cambridge in the 1700s
this is university of cambridge
this is what bcpl looks like if you've
never seen it
so it's weird and scary looking and i
don't understand why they say c
is based on it but i guess it is i'm
going to draw your
attention to uh to one thing here i
believe these are variable declarations
so compared to see what's different
there's no types right so bcpl
is not dynamically typed you'd have to
be crazy to design a dynamically typed
language in the 60s right
and it's not type inferred you would
have to be equally crazy
um instead it's uni-typed right bcpl
yeah
i understand lisp and ml um bcpl is unit
typed it only has one type in the entire
language and that type is a word or a
cell
or the thing you can fit in a register
so when richie came along
and created c he's like i'm going to add
types to c so the question is what was
he doing it for
and we'll do it multiple choice tell was
it a to prove correctness
we have you know curry howard
isomorphism programming is getting too
easy maybe we should
let people write proofs while they
program that makes it more fun
catching type errors is good right no
one likes to ship type errors maybe it
could be that
could be to generate faster code c has a
reputation for being one of the fastest
languages out there maybe that's why uh
maybe it's for toolability you know all
the awesome ides of the 60s
it turns out no uh e none of the above
so let's let's play pretend we're going
to pretend that we're a compiler
um which is a terrible use of your
imagination
and imagine that we are compiling this
expression a plus b for a pdp
um and we've already generated the code
to load a and b into registers and we're
sitting on this plus operator and we're
like what do we do now
let's see if i can use the little thing
this is a little bit tricky for us
because we're compiling for this new
fancy pdp 1140
and this has a floating point
coprocessor so now we have one of two
instructions we could generate here
either an integer out or a floating
point ad
what do we do um so previous languages i
think b
their kind of cop-out was like oh we'll
make different operators um but that
seemed like kind of a gross choice so
richie said well
we'll add types and then we'll pick the
operator based on the types of the
operands
so here's a direct quote i'll read it
because reading richie is awesome
said for all these reasons it seemed
that a typing scheme was necessary to
cope with characters and bite addressing
here he's basically describing the same
problem but for strings
and to prepare for the coming floating
point hardware so
he also understands the value of other
stuff too
but the original motivation for c having
a type system was just so that they knew
which machine code to generate for me
this is the most interesting part of
this talk because i didn't know this
until i
wrote the talk and i understand c's type
system more now so
there's things in in cs type system that
always seemed weird to me so like c has
type defs which are pretty cool and you
can imagine using it like oh i'm going
to type def my
ins to be this name inches so that i can
keep track of my units and that way i'll
get
compile errors if i try to cross units
but then c is like ah i'll just let you
freely convert them
which seems not helpful um likewise you
can define enums you'd be like a color
can only be one of these three things
and c is like oh you could do a number
two that's fine um and the reason it
allows you to do this is because it
doesn't need to prohibit this in order
to know what machine code to generate
and that's really its intent
you know okay so how does this
relate to dart i said dart sub
dynamically typed language which it is
this is valid dart code
um but you can also add type annotations
that sparkle
when you do so this is fine so when you
add type annotations
some static typing machinery comes into
play and then the question is
why did we do that and what value do we
think it provides
so option a to prove correctness
uh turns out the answer for dart that
we've chosen is no um
here's here's my my theory on this so
there i think there's a
triad of type system features i don't
know if you saw martin odersky's keynote
this morning but he had like a graph
space i'm just going to do
a venn diagram so you can have simple
type systems
you can have sound type systems in that
if there are no
type errors at compile time you are
assured that there are no type errors at
runtime
or you can have expressive type systems
where if the program is dynamically
correct the type system will let you
effectively run that program and it
won't prevent you from running it
but my theory is that no one has come up
with a type system that's all three so
you only get to pick two
so over here in simple and expressive
you get early java you get go and see
where you have a very simple type system
it fits in your head it's really nice
any program you want to write in those
languages you can write it and you can
get the type checker to shut up
by just adding some casts but the
downside is you've added some casts so
now you're not really sound anymore
once you want to be a little stricter
then you get over to haskell java with
generics scala c plus bus where you have
these very complicated
expressive type systems and you can be
you know much greater confidence that if
it compiles that it's correct
but you lose you know any hope of
simplicity right like no one would claim
that those type systems are simple
and if they do those people are geniuses
and they're not the same category
as programmers like me so i don't i
can't relate to them
so dart oh sorry and then the other one
is simple and sound and it's hard to
find languages that fit in this pascal
was the best thing i could come up with
my theory is that if a programmer knows
their programs dynamically correct they
won't suffer a language that prevents
them from running it
that's why i think it's slightly less
inhabited
so so dart's over here so we've chosen a
language to be simple and
expressive we think simplicity is really
important because
as a web language we have to target both
people that like type systems and people
coming from dynamic languages that
aren't really interested in types at all
so their
their tolerance for type system
complexity is very low um
and at the same time we want it to be
expressive because they're used to
writing dynamic programs that they know
do the right thing and they don't want
the type checker to
to tell them that they're bad and they
should feel bad um
so what we've the sacrifice we've made
is that dart's type system is not fully
sound
right it doesn't mean it's unsafe like c
you're not going to go into like bad
memory land and
take down your browser because the the
runtime semantics are dynamic
it just means that the type system
doesn't promise that you won't get a
method not found exception
so we're not trying to prove the absence
of type errors but that doesn't mean
we're not trying to help you catch them
but we just treat it more like an
empirical science you know your
your program has 100 bugs maybe maybe
you're a great maybe your program has
two bugs
if we can help you find one at static
analysis time that's great like that's
just adding value to your life
we help you find that bug you fix it you
move on and if if we didn't find all of
them
well if you had no type system you would
have found none of them so that's still
like
better than nothing right and we think
we can actually find a pretty good
number of them with a pretty simple type
system
we don't use the types to generate
faster code so the the dna of the dart
team is a bunch of
vm hackers who've been optimizing
dynamic languages since forever these
are people that
whose names are on the self papers and
they've never felt the need to be
statically
typed to be fast um but we do care a
whole lot about
toolability i say autocomplete here
there's a shorthand for all sorts of
toolability
um so how many of you work on a program
regularly that's
greater than 10 000 lines of code
almost all of us greater than a hundred
thousand
million i've worked on stuff longer than
a million before
don't know how big it is because it's a
mishmash of third party library some of
which you have contributed to and you're
not really sure how to draw the boundary
there you go so you know how when you're
new to a code base
and any time you try to do a tiny change
there's this like hour long discovery
process of like walking through call
trees and trying to figure out where
things are defined and then you're like
oh here's my one line
of code and then you sort of repeat and
eventually as you learn it more that
gets better
when you're working on a million line
code base you never leave that mode
right like you're always
in discovery mode you're always
exploring the code base and
things like toolability are are
extremely helpful there if the
if the software can tell you here i know
where it was defined i'll just take you
there if it can tell you i
know every place that's being called so
if you rename it i can do it safely um
so we do think toolability's super
important
it's hard to so the idea here is is a
about
simple types and it was hard for me to
come up with the right adjective here if
i was odersky i would say cutting corner
types
i think which i think is a slight
there's a value
negative value proposition there um i
one way i kind of look at dart's type
system is it's kind of like a
uh like a good roommate in that like if
you make a mess it will try to help you
clean it up
um and it doesn't really ask for much in
return like it doesn't put a lot of
demands on you um
i know that kind of sounds i don't know
if that sounds weasely but
it's interesting using dart's type
system in practice because
even with things like covariance which
is you know
to many people a terrible thing to just
be like yeah we'll just make the generic
covariant it turns out in practice
almost all of your usage
usages of generics are dynamically sound
in a covariant way
it's really rare that we do things in
contra variants so
even a simple type system actually works
pretty well
okay language number three the last
language
i'll just do this kind of free
association style so i'll just say out
words and then
whatever comes to mind so functional
parentheses
persistent okay good
that's an easy one um i picked this book
randomly just to have some book i'm not
saying that this is the best or worst
closure book
i haven't read closure books in fact i
know
not as much closure as i do the other
languages in this talk so if i get stuff
wrong
um tell me so that i can be less dumb
okay so let's say we're a web language
client web language we're trying to
write a little web program
that gets the the labels of all the
non-empty buttons on the page and kind
of
makes a little list out of them so dart
kind of comes from the imperative c
tradition so you could
you could write it like this and this i
think you guys can kind of figure out
what's going on here
query here is um the function in the dom
for doing a dom course like dollar sign
in jquery we just sort of built it
directly into the dom api
so this is okay um but it's kind of
gross right like it's
it's imperative there's a lot of
mutation you're explicitly creating a
list
um you're you know like the if you kind
of look at the character count it's
really a lot of the code here is just
how it's actually building this list and
not very much of it is sort of what the
actual intent behind it is
so here now if we were to do this
enclosure
we get something like this and this is
presumably closure script and using
domi which i hopefully am doing
correctly here i'm not exactly sure
so here we're doing this uh the selector
query to get all the buttons
we map them by their text labels filter
out the ones that aren't nil
join them together and we're done and to
me this is really beautiful code right
like i feel like it reads like
is showing what what my intent is and
not what are the
mechanical semantics of the underlying
language the only thing that's a little
weird is you have to read it bottom up
um but closure has this nice little oops
this nice little macro here that lets
you kind of pipeline things so that's
really cool
now the reason closure can do this is
because closure has cool two
really cool things going for it it has
this iseq
uh interface protocol extraction
this thing where any any
value that can be iterated over
traversed walked
sequenced generated supports this this
protocol
and then there are a very large number
of functions that consume and return
these isinks there's all these higher
order functions that
transform them make new ones consume
them
um and these are basically your building
blocks for that sort of
declarative aggregate collection code
and it turns out in dart we have pretty
much the same thing so we have an
iterable
interface any object that you know you
can err
over implements this and that interface
divine
defines a very large number of methods
including you know kind of all your
the functional transformers greatest
hits you know we've got map and fold and
stuff like that
you may be wondering how much of a pain
is it to implement this interface this
is a case where mixins
come in handy there's a mix in that
gives you all of these implementations
for free in terms of a smaller number of
methods so in your own type you just mix
that in and you're good to go
so if we use this in that dart example
what you get is this which is
pretty much you know modulo syntax
differences identical to the closure
code we're doing the query
we map it by its text filter out the
non-null ones join them together
um and and i i should stress that this
is vanilla dart code right so there's no
third-party libraries here so dart has
its own dom library its own core
libraries and we deeply integrated these
collections into the dom library so like
you
you do a dom query you get back
something that is a full featured
collection with all of these nice
methods on it
now there's another nice thing going on
in the closure code
and in the dark code here which is that
all of these transformations
are lazy um so i can give you another
example so here
here's some dart code and we're creating
an iterable
that generates the sequence of numbers
from 1 to 10 million
and then we're doing some stuff to it
right like we're filtering out the odd
ones or
filtering in even ones mapping them
squaring them
then we take the first 10 walk it and
print them and
if we were doing this stuff eagerly
obviously this would make your computer
sad right you don't want to build a
giant list of 10 million things
and then discard you know 99 99 of them
um so what it does is like all of these
objects are returning these wrapped lazy
sequences that only actually
invoke these transformations when the
very tail end pumps it when it starts
actually pulling stuff out and that's
really nice because it means these
generators and these transformations can
be
computationally expensive they can have
side effects that you want to control
so i think that's i think that's really
cool i've got some i should have used
the highlighting while i was talking but
i didn't
so i think laziness is nice here but um
there's kind of like there's there's
more lazy than lazy right and that the
thing that's more lazy than lazy is
asynchrony
and we have something really cool here i
kind of jam this in at the last minute
so hopefully i'm okay on time
so how many of you guys saw rich
hickey's keynote about
channels it's a great talk right so
dart has this class called stream and
it's
80 semantically similar to his idea of
channels
um where it is a a
asynchronous producer consumer of values
so you can
put values into a stream if you have the
controller for it and then you can read
values out of the stream and this all
happens asynchronously
but on top of that we added the exact
same higher order functions
that the normal iterable interface has
so you can you know map
and filter and all this stuff and now
you're doing the same operations but
you're doing them asynchronously and you
get a new
asynchronous stream in return and what's
really exciting about this so
towards the end of rich's talk you know
he said okay here's this beautiful world
we've created but over here is the dom
and you kind of there's a certain amount
of like duct tape involved
going from event handling land to nice
channel land but with dart we control
the dom api and this is in our core
library so what we did
is we just made the actual event
handlers be streams
so when you get a button and you look at
its mouse down
event that event is a stream of mouse
events and that means you can
you can filter it out map it listen to
it
create new streams in response to it so
here this is going to print every time
you shift click it's going to print
where you clicked it um
and i really like code like this i get
excited by this kind of stuff
okay so and again i will stress that
this is vanilla dark code
so the the kind of it's hard to figure
out how to encapsulate but the idea that
i'm going for here is that if you have
if your system has powerful collections
and
powerful ways to sort of transform and
modify those
um i think that's just a huge
performance not
productivity boost for everyone using
your language and it's particularly
important
for collections and in the core
libraries because it means all
third-party code
can can interoperate with these so i
don't have to
get a dumb list from some third-party
library wrap it in my nice list that
uses an ip
api i really like you sort of get the
nice list immediately right because
we're all agreeing on that
um so
these are the four ideas that i kind of
wanted to run through this is sort of
my list of stuff that i think was
interesting about dart that it has
i think a simpler semantics compared to
some other web languages or
in particular languages just have longer
histories and accumulated more cruft
but at the same time it has a pretty
familiar approachable syntax
it has a neat kind of simple type system
that
tries to help you as much as it can
without forcing you to do a lot of
theorem proving and kind of work
and then it has a really really nice
standard library that for me is sort of
a joy to use
so when i wrote this talk i got to the
slide and i was like okay here's the
summary
but i feel like it misses the the kind
of the feel of what it's like to use a
language and
it's strange being in my position where
i talk to people that haven't used dart
and they're like well what's
dart like and it's like it's one of
those things that just doesn't seem to
transfer very well across people
um but the so this is kind of my
my sort of attempt to describe like how
dart feels to me
um i'm a lot of my programming history
is in object-oriented languages i've
written lots of c
plus and java and like i really like
classes i like objects i like
especially at the macro level organizing
my programs
in terms of like objects that interact
with each other like it feels natural to
me i understand that like at strange
loop
maybe this is a heretical statement but
like this is a comfortable way for me to
organize
code and i like the idea of sort of you
know classes as being kind of a unit of
modularity
but at the same time i'm really
comfortable with a lot of functional
features i
i like closures i like higher order
functions i like
i really like not having to use classes
for things that aren't stateful
you know like sometimes all you need is
a function right um
and my experience writing dart is that
it's one of the few languages i've used
that feels like it does both of these on
pretty equal footing you know like i've
i've tried f-sharp and i've tried other
languages that sort of try to be
multi-paradigm and they they usually
kind of feel like they're sort of
bolted together you know whereas dart if
i write dart code that doesn't create
any classes
it feels like legit dark code to me and
if i write dart code that has lots of
classes like that's legit dark code too
and that makes it for me kind of a fun
language to use
so if any of that sounds fun to you
i would highly encourage you to check
out dartlang.org
we have lots of fun stuff here we've got
documentation
we've got a language spec specs are nice
people like language specs written by
galad braca
famous language spec guy
we've got some tutorials we've got a
bunch of sample code starts a web
language so the samples run in your
browser which is kind of neat
we've got an entire book which is kind
of cool uh that's you know you can also
just get for free from the site
um and as a language nerd kind of the
coolest thing is we have
try.dartlang.org
which lets you just compile dart code in
your browser and the way it works is our
dart to javascript compiler is written
in dart so we compiled it with itself to
javascript stuck it in a web page and
now you can kind of just try out dart on
the web which is pretty cool
and that's it so i have no idea how i'm
doing on time when am i supposed to be
done
over by four i'm very sorry for whoever
is coming after me
if you have questions and would love to
talk to me would like to talk to me i
would love to talk to you so just come
bug me at any point in time
thank you